you will not be jumping about 50 bucks
that I knew you're right
new sir not New York not full of yet not
know where would you say 500 500 you
making uh jump somebody spot
[Music]
hello customers and welcome back in my
shop if this is your first time here
thank you for finally joining us my name
is Fahim Alexander and I'm a
professional one with himself love you
for today's episode we will be
replicating in an iconic look worn by
the pop star trick this haircut is
another modern classic a skin face
Caesar with a hook punch on the top left
side we're going to be joined today by
the smooth cool brother with trip and
he's gonna be letting us smash his hair
come on in the truck man you saw me did
you play basketball in your time horse
man of course got to represent so I'm to
the 205 it's a little far from him get
out of here that's what my boots start
at so um do you do you like Drake yeah I
like three I thought or I should think
you know you look pretty cool yet with
nice can't really like but I like what
I'm working you don't maybe give you
that tapir haircut there because I'm off
the top we keep it as smooth part I
really like the part in yes particularly
you know this world all know what you
call it but it's like you just know this
I know what you want right but it
Philadelphia we call it the hood
what a nice park nas had that part first
in the 90s so Drake has what a couple
variations of this haircut through the
year check it out man so we look at that
a dark Caesar here with ways more like
like a two inch on top this is how a rig
right here he's wearing his hair a
little heavy with the suit on so what do
you think right there caste copy coming
in same thing Bobby they say got that
nice smooth beard sort of like what you
have he's wearing his hair heavy maybe
like a three or four curly top natural
look so in this photo right here this is
a beard face yeah like this
is really nice I don't know how long it
took him to grow dead this is like my
favorite trick look right here when he
has like a faint like a two on top his
waves are starting to spin but he's
missing something the part hard the hook
hook okay okay this is what I want right
here can you hook me up a short kid this
is the Kiki says you never gonna lead me
beside in the parking lot down the
street
well mighty twist oh man machito's so we
gonna get this roll
let's go got my 357 from caliber my kobe
edition know what you're doing so we
gonna start on the right side of this so
I worked my way around the back area you
starting that thing this is my canvas
you know I need top of the cranium just
like that's it for the air this is gonna
be my work area
I just make sure we be cleaning all the
way around the board when doing this
particular cut is very important to make
it even guideline the next step that I
want to do is start trimming some of
this hair off I didn't quite use your
budget because I need to cut a level off
so I can start to see which direction
that hair goes how do you think the
barbershop became a place where you know
people who talk about anything you have
all walks of life they're coming to the
barbershop all different men that share
different experiences in life so you can
relate some something you can't believe
but it's just different people there's
just experience a whole lot of different
levels in life some of the best business
goes on in the barber shop so I'm gonna
best business you don't need to know it
as well
yeah so I think I got it down to where I
needed that he goes forward it's curly
right now like pretty much like natural
but you can see like the wave pattern
moving forward out of too hard to put on
this little strange right
I've had this much hair cut off in a
long time man you got spiders in his
little bicycles
I'll let you look at it you may want to
take it a little lower depending on how
fast you want to come back to the
barbershop how low your low you can get
loads mine now if you go mono that mean
you got to worry about the Flies landing
on your head and scratching his knees
I'm starting to feel like Drake now Kiki
where she's at
Kiki Oh vocals coming in so I do drop
down a little lower someone had the kind
of smaller guard yep that's it I'm gonna
keep it your clipper extension is on
your clipper with those a lever on the
sides adjustable this is like for like
lower haircuts when you cut in lower
like skin tapers and fades use the
extension but once you start going into
taking down or fading into a bulk you
want to use a guard for safety how do
you feel about I'm loyal clients
sometimes you know you might be a
customer they make they go to another
barber how do you feel about those I
mean I wanna see like where I'm at right
now in my career it doesn't it doesn't
bother me
it makes room for like new clients that
could not be get my chair so I used all
my guards that I'm gonna use so I'm
gonna just turn the level all the way up
so I can start to knocks it online just
pick me at it that's what you want to do
you don't want to go up to make any new
guidelines on elitism I'm always looking
great we're right on time right on
schedule
so right now I've been cutting here for
so long so it's like I don't even have
to look at the clipper or anything like
that it's got a natural it's kind of
natural to me now like the Clipper just
talks to
using leather you have and finally I
won't charge you don't make you give it
a haircut here yeah that's pretty cool
what's my mains to pay for Indiana
pieces just like this man you don't talk
to Danny Granger Oh division there to
Granger that's exactly who you look like
that's something everybody has a twin
through everybody has it's one in this
world
what's my guy that Russell's marking and
I got eight up in the comments last time
people say mark henry transition over to
Barbara and very well the monster nine
nine and caliber I get some detail work
done with this and sharp lines on the
beer shot lies on the shape up has there
never been
unfixable Hema oh I'm actually like the
fixed cricket hair loss
it's one of my signatures so all to the
left side of the cut you want to keep it
though
just start working it that walk down the
wait in the hairline to start tapering
it so I can get the guyline out-- you
ever get nervous chemist and everything
are not at all some I wonder are you
know I've cut you won't call me back but
sometime I really want to know like
maybe you really like the haircut
I feel so change right now yeah you
change me or just refinish them to be
one of my favorite tunes in the
barbershop
feathers
it's important stress is skinny we're
using the reason so I'm just a bum all
guns but I need a broom break you got to
have a clean yeah here man this is my
first job sweeping the floor in the
barber shop this was the beginning the
evolution of the five the barber this
job right here it seems it saves lives
be honest with you when you hire a young
man or you hire a young lady that wants
to do barbering this is sort of like
their first job I take pride in this job
take I'm ready to cut this part in I'm
gonna get another pair of clippers just
the blade just wasn't thin enough to
give me a Chris line this I got my pink
Gloucester luster it's all she is hair
dry the boy who takes away the dry this
over here all right
I'm ready man
Aaron okay used to call me on my cell
phone I haven't had my hat this is low
and oh wow though I'm having it some way
the part is nice I like okay thank you
appreciate your bed for sir thank you
thank you and last but not least you
look like a
ex-nba player I want to challenge you to
a game of trash ketball trash the ball
say no ah let's do it
so this is the rules control to get
three shots I get three shots and stuff
let's go okay Oh
[Applause]
I appreciate you my brother you say -
this is your yeah today we've seen a
drink the fade the hook part and the
scruffy beard come check us out next
time until then be good look good feel
good inside the lies of athletes like me
[Music]
[Applause]
there's gonna be room which they're
going to have professional hockey
players shoot over slap shot